je passe transformation bon avant et
après une heure avant le lever de rideau
les comédiens de la troupe du crâne vont
jouer sur la scène de l'espace albert
camus le stress commence à monter petit
à petit c'est vrai que c'est la première
fois qu'on joue cette pièce sur celle là
je dirais que il n'ya plus qu'à laisser
venir un peu les émotions le stress qui
grimpent eux gentiment et puis on sera
prêt pour pour 8h30
cette année pour le festival de maurepas
ils ont choisi les comptes
le petit chaperon rouge en amuse-gueule
qu'elles sont content d'arriver à
trouver l'atmosphère le cocon dans tout
ça
que ce soit comme un nuage une chose
lointaines comme un rêve et la belle et
la bête leurs dernières créations
une plongée dans l'univers enfantin pour
cette troupe qui fête cette année ses 35
ans sa particularité
tous les comédiens sont amateurs comme
le football on a deux entraînements par
semaine et anjou le week-end voilà donc
c'est un peu ça non mais ça nous fait du
bien à tous de quitter le travail est de
retrouver l'esprit où on peut faire
autre chose c'est le paradis j'étais
professeur d'art dramatique
je me suis retrouvé ici c'était des
champs à perte de vue et j'étais
désespéré parce que l'amour de ma vie
c'est mon théâtre et si vous voulez
j'étais à la mairie tout simplement
demander s'il n'y avait pas local
susceptible de me recevoir et où
j'aurais pu commencer à faire un embryon
de troupes
on est vraiment scellé par par l'amour
et la folie du théâtre parce qu'il faut
un petit peu de folie la passion et il
faut une certaine rigueur des comptes de
la poésie ou encore du théâtre de
boulevard avec une nouvelle pièce chaque
année la troupe se produit
principalement dans les châteaux
franciliens